Coleman okay so there was this big
conference flock the Federated logic
conference that some of the people here
are also attending
and it was floating around
so let me start by just giving the
definition and then we can see where it
comes from and um
how it relates to other proof systems
okay so this is a
proof system force or another refutation
system for CN apps so given a CNF
CNF
e
hitting refutation
is
is a partition
very important it's a partition
of 0 1 to the n
into sub cubes
that
for every
foreign
cubes
c i
every through the sum and Alpha and CI
falsifies
with s s i falsifies the clause
C J where J depends only on I okay maybe
I wrote it in a complicated way
so this is some kind of partition of the
space of all twist assignments okay into
monochromatic rectangles or in this case
sub cubes we're in each sub Cube all the
assignments falling into this sub Cube
they refute the same Clause of feet
okay
so maybe it's also clear what I mean by
a sub Cube so here are some examples or
one example of a sub Cube let's say X1
equals one and X2 equals zero okay so
this is what I mean by sub Cube
just two dimensions
foreign
specify some of the coordinates
okay this is a sub Cube yeah so for
example if you have a tree like red
resolution proof then each branch would
be such a sub Cube excellent so where
does it come from
yeah so it's exactly what Russell said
so
for example
every
pre-like resolution reputation
[Music]
of Phi is
also
hitting
reputation of five
okay so let me remind you or maybe some
of you have never heard of trilak
resolution and we still are here in this
conference and workshop on perform like
today which is good for you yeah
so also happens when you write like this
yeah all right
okay don't forget what I wrote it's
maybe it's so formal that it's hard to
understand
every course for one particular Clause
they're associated with each sovereign
for all sub cubes
forever
there exists
CJ in C
such that if
Alpha is a switch assignment in si then
Alpha
falsifies
a day
and hopefully there's no room for
disagreements
okay so for example a Trader resolution
proof is really a decision tree that
solves the falsified Clause problem okay
like Russell said if you look at every
leaf every leaf is monochromatic all the
assignments making it to every leaf they
falsify the same class which is the
label obviously
and if you look at all the leaves
together then they form a partition of
the space of all truth assignments
okay so what the heating proof system
says this partition of zero one to the
end there's no reason for for it to come
from a decision tree it could just be
any other any partition
yeah I think it's it's very natural
okay so maybe the first question we have
to ask is is this a proof system
which means is it efficiently verifiable
so how would you verify that the given
partition of 0 1 to the N satisfies uh
this property so okay one thing is easy
so I can label every
every sub cube with this clause and and
you can easily check this condition okay
this means that
if you think of the sub Cube as a clause
then it must be a weakening of this of
CJ okay
but how do we know that it's a partition
if I give you a partition of 0 1 to the
N how do you this how do you verify the
data partition
it's a special case
well this is a completely arbitrary
partition so I'm giving you a partition
of 0 to the n
okay so one condition uh one thing is
that I want to verify that every two
subjects are disjoint okay so if they
are disjointed they must disagree on the
value of some variable
okay so that's how to verify that the
different sub cubes are disjoint how do
I verify that they cover all truth
assignments
right I sum up the number of assignments
covered by each subpoop and the answer
should be two to the N so can you just
um
uh okay
see if you just add them up and they
should be the formal polynomial one yeah
so I will also calculate that you also
call the infested probabilistically no
that's not true yeah
so here also has seen my talking is uh
let's see
okay so just to say that this is known
as model accounting we're using model
counting to count how many assignments
satisfy your given sub here and this is
what I learned
yeah so as I said this is a kind of a
generalization of tree like resolution
so we can ask how does it compare with
three like resolution so Russell you
must know the answer
it should be stronger
stronger okay how stronger
um
here so this will make
you consider it right so I just write
the title hitting
there's a tree like resolution
so claim number one
okay three like resolution
simulates
okay
okay so I won't explain it in full I
will just uh sketch the proof a little
while there is some time
yeah so actually we have one proof like
this in the paper but I never understood
it so I'll give the profile understand
yeah
this is like similar to like up Inner
Circle up that's exactly yeah okay sorry
yeah so you can do it this way but here
is the way I I remember how to do it
so in the paper we have both words
so we have our uh our heating formula
and it has let's say m different sub
cubes Little M yeah capital N with you
so one of these sub cubes must cover
um one over M fraction of all truth
assignments
so it mentions that moles log M
variables
now like we said every two sub cubes
must conflict there must have some
variable they disagree on
so in particular one of these login
variables must be very popular and one
of the truth assignments to this
variable is going to rule out many sub
cubes
and I will do some calculation and you
get this quadric polynomial simulation
and this I'm told is very similar to the
way that you automate uh you like a
solution
okay so this is how to show the tree
like resolution what the point number is
similar achieving
um if you are very careful
you don't have to be very careful but if
you actually
see what you get then we end up with um
resolution proof of side m to the log M
Times log n where m is the size of the
the number of sub cubes in the heating
proof and N is the number of variables
but we think that the right answer
should be m to the log m
so there's a small Gap there
okay now we also have a separation
all of these to be exactly disjoint or
we can overlap as well yeah it's like an
overlap you essentially get everything
so because fee is already approved right
sorry so you can take fear if you don't
require this to be a prediction you can
just take fee itself
but if there's bounded over that then
something to talk about yes what was the
point about mm
yeah so
let's say that the number of sub cubes
is linear in number of variables so we
have only one parameter n
so our simulation is n to the log
squared n but we think there should be a
simulation of n to the login
and why do we think because that's the
best separation we can get
no no sorry uh so what I was meaning was
for each label yeah the cubes that label
a particular Clause yeah they would
overlap with each other right
they need not be perfect they need not
be uh
poverty is still okay
but this makes sense if you uh if you
allow only a moderate amount of
um poly log amounts
Four Brothers
we might get to it uh
later
okay so we have a separation so
I think
can be
multiply normally
more efficient
then through that resolution
and how do we prove that so
if you like resolution it corresponds to
decision tree depth in the sense that if
you lift this in if you take some
function well which has some this is
for some career complexity and you
compose it with xor then it lifts to a
decision tree size okay so there's some
kind of Correspondence between the two
and the corresponding complexity measure
for the hitting group system is
EP energy
no it's not the complexity measure so
again we have a Boolean function
yeah
and I'm saying that there is some
connection between the complexity
measure query complexity and decision
automatic rectangles covers by
monochromatic rectangles okay so this is
like a SAT this is too strong
um
because this
is by
this thing
separation
frame
which is very complexity
and you see which is unambiguous
certificate
complexity
so the setting here is another component
function so we have a function from 0 1
to 10 to zero one then we're considering
two different complexity measures
one of them is a free complexity just
the depth of the shallowest decision
tree
or a function and the other one is a
so-called unambiguous certificate
complexity okay
so this is the minimal width of a system
of unambiguous certificates for the
function what's the system of final
bigger significance of the function just
a partition of zero one to the N to a
monochromatic substance of the function
and the width is the maximum number of
coordinates set by any of these objects
this is this convection as you see it's
not in the tables so if you've ever
opened a paper on the QT technique then
there are these huge tables and the UC
is not there so people don't care about
it maybe now they will care about it
some people it's not nickel this time
it's this akk paper and some doctors are
here
and they give a separation between the D
and your C
so they get a function where the query
complexity is a lot more but not only
larger than the elements of complexity
and if you take this function and you
lift it you compose it with xor and two
bits
and then we get a separation between a
decision tree size and uh
well remember the corresponds to hitting
and that's how we get the separation
including hitting and trick resolution
the reason why I'm telling you all this
is because of the next bullet point
which is relation to resolution
okay
but the question is at this point
yeah so this is to the previous Point
does this mean automatically that you
can be from employability yeah
perfect
in fact yeah you look at the the
quality polynomial
algorithm for
a tree like resolution it may actually
be looking for a hitting a hitting uh
pretty directly
um so pretty directly now because uh
until we tried and the uh that's like at
some point but Sudan and the student
Gaia
student
someone she's working with they think
that they can do it but so far it hasn't
been
thank you versus resolution
okay so in One Direction this question
is not so complicated so can resolution
be especially more efficient than
hitting yes because it can be more than
a tree like resolution yeah yes
lose something in the exponent because
thank you
okay now what about the other direction
so 10 resolution P simulated or is there
a positive binomial separation
for the all things
you said that it can be more efficient
yeah so I'm asking whether okay so we
saw that hitting does not have PC relate
or positive pronouncing weight
resolution because there's actually an
exponential separation so there's some
formula which is a lot more a lot easier
for resolution than a true like
resolution
are sort of the same and it's also
exponentially smaller
easier for resolution than for hitting
so you want to speed up in both language
I don't know what I want I want to know
the truth
so now we want to know whether hitting
can be better than resolution so it
could only be a
bit better but can it be better
so we have a quantify analysis operation
between
Heating and true that resolution so
keeping can be somewhat better than
three luck resolution can it also be
somewhat better than resolution or
perhaps resolution P simulates Heating
you could use a stronger lifting and get
the same separation program that's also
what I think so and we don't know how to
show it okay we don't know
right there
solution
he simulates
so some people here that tried to prove
it so it might be true
but if we didn't want to try to prove a
separation then what we will need to do
is we would need to replace this ledger
to replexity with that grid which is
this funny measure
okay so that width is this game
I'm trying to find an
um
I can ask the guy holding the assignment
okay so what's the value of X5 what's
the value of X7
and then at some point I can say okay so
you know what I don't care about X5
anymore
and I can continue this way and if I use
W memory then this is not enough amount
of w on the diagram
why is it all done with because if I uh
you know compose it with
xor then it lifts to dive sides to the
size of a resolution
so if there's a better separation
multiple queer complexity and UC but
between that width and you see
techniques they don't seem to work so
because we don't have any other
technique of the separation and maybe
it's false
so we can't show that resolution
increasing relative I mean maybe it's
false but even if it's true we don't
know how to show it
so what other proof system we simulates
um hitting for sure
we already heard the answer yes
okay
yeah so
so this is a p simulating
thing
okay
so you can convert every sub Cube into
an extended monomial this is monomial
also in the migration of variables which
is one if I'm in the subgroup and zero
otherwise
yeah and then I can sum all these
monomials and I should be getting one
okay so maybe I get something like this
yeah so why am I getting one so for
every zero one assignment I'm getting
one and because this is not linear then
it has to be the one point on it
okay so this is the kind of proof
so which systems what systems can
actually Express this proof
yes
it should be a
um
the problem is that you don't have any
like restriction on the degree so it
could be five degree terms because the
certificates might be large
um even though the average certificate
is small which is IPS
okay so um
somebody contacted I believe uh
he knew the answer immediately
you know we understand somebody related
to treatment here
PCR
okay so we want to check the identity of
two polynomials what should we use
what do you use to test Model 2.0 is
identical
which key idea applies here
not committed
right for example
so
there is a nice um
in this case it gets even simpler and
using this uh
pit you can
well check for yourself but this
identity actually evolves and this kind
of proof you can
rewrite in extended PC
foreign
maybe that's like um
you don't expect it to be very tight
yeah but this is definitely true okay
about resolution like I can't say it
very much
yeah so um
yeah we can express this
standard trigger
okay now that we're here we can consider
a slightly different group system okay
so this is all I have to say about
hitting for now so maybe we positive
again for questions
okay so we don't have uh commutative in
general
clear because you can order the
variables in the same order in each of
the terms then this will be true even
non-commeritable
and this you can actually test
so it's a very content
and in this particular case it's it's
even easier than the general case
[Music]
that size why don't you just put all the
terms well
yeah so this was just what I was going
to get through uh
so now in the remaining time I'm going
to discuss a few other
questions which are similar to Heating
and the first one is odd Heating
so and then tell it but actually the
subject I hear it makes sense to apply
it over a finite field so let's say over
gf2
so it's it's enough if you just know
that this is true over gf2
okay so if I have um collection of sub
cubes which covers every point exactly
and all number of times
and this is more or less yeah
I think this is simulated by PCR
because every right so why don't why do
you need all these strong purposes
yeah you can do it with one so every
every partition the number of members in
your petition is going to correspond to
the number of monomials
but no you have but how do you like you
add them up it actually equals one but
how do you prove that it equals one yeah
okay so like vanilla thinks it's
impossible so we should talk to them
okay so it's true that what you can do
is you can replace each of these things
by transcribe
okay
and also module x i plus x i bar is
equal to one
okay but individual systems like um that
will be more natural you would also need
to use this to
okay
pit yeah
yeah so and it happens so this variant
of motion Thoughts with neural variables
without the contaminary direction this
is also a good system because you can
use the same ones with a PID
we think or other Mark thinks that if
you have to use these uh these
complementary accent then in some cases
it will cost you a lot tomorrow
[Music]
aside but we don't know how to show it
okay so in the one that we have left I
mentioned briefly the tumorable system
speaking class and repeating two
okay so he didn't think this is um
well hitting over linear equations so
now instead of sub to the assigned
subspaces so this is a transition of
tree like resplus
but this simulation that I explained the
positive connection doesn't work or we
don't know
so we don't know
if a tree request plus a quality
polarization with hitting plus you don't
know another thing hitting too is when
every tooth assignment is covered at
most twice
okay so using including explosion you
can actually test this so this is also a
proof system and we think that it should
be quantity polynomial estimation for
from hitting and this would follow
from a separation between UC and uc2
where in uc2 we have a system of
certificates but it has only valid
ambiguity so every point is covered in
close watch but again we don't know how
to improve this separation we can teach
you both work and we don't have any of
it
okay so that's all I have to say
so if you're interested you can look it
up yeah questions
yeah
um so in
um work with William Matthews and Mohan
patrory so we were looking at sat
algorithms for ac0 and I think
what we get is we get a partition into
sub Cube disjoint sub cubes where each
uh where the function is constant for an
eac0 function I don't know whether that
might help in showing that hitting says
kind of hitting proofs non-trivially uh
non-trivially you know slightly so
exponentially simulates uh AC zero Prego
or something like that
another favor
can you ask a question
you say like a candidate Pig
um no I should also say that this
creative doesn't work for hitting Plus
yeah we tried like a few other things
and this is the first thing that works
so
much
it's probably
thank you